today let's show adult toys that sounds
way dirtier than I meant it
toys for grown-ups and for kids it's
Batman the Animated Series 25th
anniversary and we're gonna look at some
sweet delectable toys that DC
collectibles is made just to celebrate
the occasion and their entire line of
Batman animated series toys today on
family
[Music]
on Batman welcome the fat man Batman I'm
Kevin Smith okay folks so right here
from D DC collectibles that that's all
right the immortal Jim Fletcher give it
up there I I know Jim going back aways
but we did a piece last year on an AMC
television program called geeking out
where we went to the DC collectibles
office and toured and looked at
everything from the birth of like when
DC first did figures which I remember
which was like Legion of super-heroes
Enuma nothing I said earlier they're
first like tentative stepping into the
realm of making stuff and there's a full
collection you can see like everything
they've ever made Plus stuff that
they've prototype and didn't make we
want to talk about that yeah we showed
it on the show too late
they did four you're absolutely right
they did a prototype of the sand The
Sandman helmet that was a nice piece
I've been produced it yet but yeah thank
you
however we haven't produced yep it's a
full size Sam and how many on you it's
probably all it goes down past the table
oh pretty it looked expensive but it
looked like something that even if you
didn't know salmon you like this would
be beautiful yeah very cool looking
thing they did like a dr. fate helmet
out of metal yeah it's got metal and
it's got gold plating on it so trying to
figure that one out I mean that's the
thing it's like someone will buy that
there are like a hundred dr. fate fans
in the world at least 100 I'm one of
them I saw that I was like oh my lord so
they make stuff that like you don't see
yet they make stuff that you see all the
time right now was the best selling for
you guys over there
well I know we're going to talk about
the Batman animated stuff and that's
been a great line for us have been going
on since like 2014 I think when we
started and people just eaten it up we
can't seem to make enough for the
characters and I'm like not just this
year like a couple days ago was the 25th
anniversary yeah right it's amazing so
literal day yeah 25 years ago they
debuted the cartoon on Fox I've imagined
if I remember yeah prime time Tuesday
yeah it was the cat in the claw I think
was like well they did I think the cat
in the claw was like the first
two-parter that they did and I think
that's what they started with and then
and
man-bat was like the first yeah that's a
regular afternoon episode I remember
taping those on VHS long before like
they would release them themselves just
taping them day after day so you had
your own collection it was breathtaking
what they were accomplished with that
cartoon they talked about like you know
in the early 90s there was an x-men
cartoon which was like insanely
influential for a lot of years that's
how they learned about the x-men but it
was kind of you know cookie-cutter very
color coloring book rendered there was
no I'm not saying it was art list but it
was kind of standard like hey man to
school animation they nobody was
thinking hey this might be for more than
just kids Batman the Animated Series
took the genre and elevated it by like
going hey simple things that aren't
simple like let's do all our backgrounds
on black and we'll paint like it'll just
give it a look let's go back to the
Fleiss your Superman cartoons for
inspiration for these characters let's
set it in a timeless world that doesn't
look like right now but isn't
necessarily back then let's let's do a
rendition of Batman and his rogues
gallery in the Batman world that it's so
recognizable from comics but they hadn't
really done in any genre not on the
Superfriends not in the Batman movies
they took like what Tim Burton was doing
with that Batman movie and ran with it
Bruce Timm Paul Dini throw out some
other rock star names Alan Burnett
Radomski always said the voice actors
alone is Kevin Conroy the great Kevin
Connery is Batman for all of us you
gotta think about that there's been many
Batman's in our lifetime plus the Batman
you have in your head when you read a
book you had Kevin Conroy Batman is so
powerful so legendary and and so
definitive that like when I read a
Batman comic that's the Batman voice
that I hear so the Batman animated story
use your own voice you think right yeah
but I sound so bad I'm like I am the
note like I sound like I sound like
Chris Christian Bale trying to sound
like a hard-ass what I need is one of
them like voice modulator what I do
defines me I can't we make that work on
that later we're working on the my
into here yeah right into your so it
picks it up just get a cold and stick
with it for a while you're watching that
yeah my starter voice is post about I'm
the night man
all right night men's different carry
there's a whole different thing we don't
want to touch there alright so let's
let's talk about Batman the Animated
Series so damn influential 25 years of
being around
I named my kit I look presumably I might
have a kid without this show but I
wouldn't have that kid's name without a
show Carly Quinn I stole it right from
the damn show Harley Quinn also
celebrating her 25th right because she
came from the animated series so how do
you find folks at DC collectibles keep
it going as you said before 2014 you
started this Batman animated series line
and everybody knows that the figures are
breathtakingly gorgeous they look like
the animated series come to life in your
hand and I've seen I collected the old
ones who did it yeah I may do I have
them all Kenner back in the day and I'm
Mattel they both yeah but these figures
man look they look like a Bruce Timm
drawing come to life and they have
spared no expense and they're doing
everybody it's not even like we're doing
the big five and moving on they're doing
deep cuts characters you guys doing
bookworm not yet that was never the
mission though just to do the top guys
walk away no not everybody yeah
bookworms coming yeah I thought your
guarantee I there you go here first
bookworm is custom custom bookworm the
the the notion of kind of diving deep in
the universe and keeping it alive and
making stuff you guys are the only
licensed now right nobody else is doing
yeah no one else is there well diamonds
make it a few busts and things but as
far as the action figures go and the and
the gigantic breadth of things is that's
nothing all coming from us
can I show them what you brought your
show come on look at how big it is I
think you're over here what do you put
not just not just these four if you turn
it there's officer Montoya oh my god
there's my boy a man which like you can
actually wind up playing the question
with you actually
what's actually really - what's great
about this too is Alden that this is no
reason cuz this stuff is all sculpted
from their all original sculpts we
didn't do the whole let's just put
something let's put an old figure in a
box and call the day so that all
brand-new sculpts so it's brand all
these are brand new yeah they all have
that they all come with their own prison
cells so when you open this up which you
brother may be unboxing can we unbox it
no should we can we I mean beautiful
really shouldn't come out of its
wrapping but just sit there like that
but its first best destiny is to be open
and played I kind of think that's no
point of making a manufactured for use
that's right well you should open it you
should be the one because you know what
went into it okay here you go
do you need a pen or something like that
there's a little sticker right opening
car keys microphones nowhere land The
Price is Right what do we have
I always took my pockets before the show
just in case is an emergency you've been
doing it before I know that's true I'm
like I can't have any sharp objects
around for them alright so there you're
seeing a pro a guy who makes the toys
Jeff you've always wondered exactly what
mixta buying if you've always been like
I'm too precious and you've gotten into
fights with girlfriends and boyfriends
about opening [ __ ] a damn pro just used
a key was like a top you get into your
fights mostly about if you should be
buying all these toys or not always good
to have a unpacking buddy and here's why
okay that's we're saving that and put it
in a mylar bag so this is not just a
snowy roof you're probably wondering
what the ding-dongs is up here for it
was actually to keep it from getting
busted up and shipping
okay so you could obviously take this
piece out it's a printed top of the box
so you can actually put your figures up
here you've seen us do the bat-signal I
know the things that you've got a whole
piece you can play with and you're
probably looking at what's this stuff
yeah there's there's some on the other
side you're seeing some look look like
LEDs or something well maybe I'll let
you do the next magical step on our
unboxing and pull this tab we move for
try me I'll hold a new pool we're team
working it
Oh so what does it do so I'll put it
back in and then you'll find out did I
do the wrong way Oh inside the cells are
basically of light so you can see all
the characters with different light up
cells which we think just looks amazing
it's when the lights are a little
lighter it's super cool looking so Ivy's
got green mr. Freeze's blue now what is
the collector to do how long did it was
just one choose to leave the lights on
can one turn that off or whatever
they'll actually turn off and you can
also just stop if you also open the
front of this thing so this so they can
see all of them in their glory in the
front here they all have their little
nametags and that's not all they each
are in individual cells and when you
take them out of here you can they're
all separate they have all their
accessories behind them let's take it
out let's do it and montoya also has her
own little piece there so okay so here's
the lid yep that'll just shut off and
it's just eventually there's their
individual cells they come in soup and
then there's when there's books oh look
what I love the book oh so I becomes of
the plant and roses and plants I'm a
bunch of different hands Mr Freeze has
his guns they all the stands we've been
doing all this time to remember before
which is great with the little drawings
turn around clip this is best when you
saw had just the ones that go this this
has a spring in it now so it works a lot
better than see what they do is they put
the the stands have the turnarounds of
the characters so classy what's
important about those things you were
talking about the accuracy of the toys
before these are actually all the
artwork from the original cells from
there's some of the development drawings
from the show which is what we base
these on and what makes them the most
different from the the toys that came up
before is these are hyper accurate
that's why they had to come with stands
cuz the ankles at that size are really
hard to you know balance when your
ankles are like this big look at the
artwork they even put a toilet in her
cell yeah well like that means that's
just practical deep cuts it's true but
but so inside that box like you
still got artwork going on and so you
can I'm not gonna tire but you know you
take your out of the plastic yeah also
the back of the bus is too nice for a
child Wow well why would you consider
yourself that it's true an adult I know
I think yet oh this is one of my faves
god damn he look people we're really
waiting for this version mr. Frese on
this idea in particular we had a lot of
requests for people I can we get to this
one already cuz I why what was that had
they never done a version like this we
done well no we there's been other ones
out there like that but they you guys
that's a question we've been doing we
haven't actually gotten to them and
we've made multiple versions of almost
everybody
and this one's finally out there and
what's super cool about this is having a
Montoya in there because we were really
trying to figure out where how do we get
her out there because he's you know in a
lot of episodes
is she gonna sell by herself not sure
but you put her with these guys in the
box and so it gives you the ability to
make a figure that was questionable
whether or not like you die with a
10,000 copies of that figure exactly so
now you could stick it in with a set and
you're like it's a chase figure yep is
the tape of defeating it open so that
cell swings out if you want to line up
all your figures at once you can have
that facing front and the whole thing
swings open well be able to get around I
think we met to get your a magical key
opening device once again or the good
old meanwhile I'm gonna take a peek look
at the croc dude he's really he's he's
because he's the only one he has the ab
crunch so you can get him it's true he's
got the articulation right in the middle
yeah it's on what sound brand to man
wait no wait that's true and it's got a
bunch of different uses this is wicked
man he looks fantastic that's really
funny I like this design the croc meat
all the designs of greenio they're all
so different from the different series
right I knew scarecrow was one of the
ones he's like the most different
looking at big giant hat on no creepy
looking so there you go she's free she's
free to catch everyone wow wow look at
big these fingers are you got yourself a
Renee Montoya and for those of you who
know DC man she becomes spoilers the
question though
in this room now they're not on the job
but how cool is that Wow someone's got
to keep these guys in line you know you
can't just have a bunch of villains out
and a five-pack special cause no
problems now this is a little drawing of
the four different artwork so there were
the four different titles of the show
right it says yeah it's got the Batman
Beyond even Superman got many new
adventures and the original one and on
the back they're showing us some of the
newer releases that are coming out which
is you got a sweet-looking Catwoman a
Riddler a Batgirl bat up there doing old
Bruce Wayne and Batman Beyond 3-pack is
amazing that's ace and Batman Beyond and
old Bruce Wayne Holiday Joker from
Christmas with the Joker episode the
Lois Lane gosh so this is suffice all
you know they all tie into the same
universe that you know was developed by
these guys so it works really well
because all the shows are very you know
the designs for the characters don't
work well together and here's an
instruction manual how to put their
hands on Tony has two different heads
she has hat and no hat just like
yourself oh my god you are inspiration
from dude pulled for me like I know a
guy sometimes this is look at the bane
dude look at how look how damn sweet so
much plastic involved yeah he's a big
guy
[Music]
just seeing the renderings of these
characters brings happy memories like of
seeing these episodes for the first time
as they unfold it like now you know most
people do deep dives and binge but I was
watching them in real time so every
afternoon as the episode ended they
would be like tomorrow on Batman the
Animated Series and you were like who's
it gonna be and suddenly they were like
oh they're doing they really it was
fanservice before there was such a term
and the shows were written really walk
so they weren't just for kids like you
couldn't watch them I know a lot of
different levels I think that's why the
show's resonated so long and why people
really relate to the filling in their
collection building a world out of stuff
that we're making it's why you'll get an
adult to pay whatever they're off to pay
for something like yes notice so let's
talk Turkey somebody wants to get this
what does something like this cost
standard retail price yeah well here
this is how much it cost that's not too
bad I think we might just have to leave
it here and everyone stop touching [ __ ]
oh no what is it so what will it cost if
somebody wants to get where do they get
it it's is it at your LCS your local
comic shop yeah it should be get them
there you can that's what we can't go to
your local comic but retail you gotta
it's like 125 I think which is for this
many figures is great if five figures
man yeah no yeah never the lights and
everything it's pretty great and you can
pick what's cool about this you can pack
all the stuff back in they given when
you cut the tags and take them out you
put it back together and look you know
besides the plastic that you're keeping
for posterity it's pretty much exactly
the same that you have you know with the
bat-signal everything else you can put
the Roxy rocket up here now they've done
the Roxy rocket you guys have done the
batwing which is big that's not gonna
fit on here that's not talking about the
vehicles like the batwing is a very big
vehicle to use figures yeah it's like
almost like the old Millennium Falcon
from the it's pretty much the same the
Batmobile is fantastic what what other
things can we see in our future T's what
else how are they going back on this
year we were super happy to roll out
that roll out now we rolled out the
Joker mobile which was only on that one
show and not even on for that long but
it just so freakin it's got a big Joker
face on there's gonna be light up eyes
and stuff that's a big deal and we also
had the the Batcave playset which is
gonna have come on Alfred a serving tray
a bunch of stickers you can like go back
in so what if this is the size of a
figure how big is the back Batcave is
the studio apartment yeah you got a rent
to place for you're building it here by
the way so yeah it's pretty big it's
probably from the friends table it's
probably fills up the width of whatever
this table is it's probably not this
high is there Wayne box of Wayne Manor
to it or is just all batkid it's just
all Batcave I mean it's a lot of other
stuff we'd like to do we were on to
really keep world building with that's
what you were asking I mean what's so
cool we've gone through so many figures
over 50 if
animal individually at this point right
and we're just trying to figure what
else do we do like you said earlier
people are so they so loved the show
they're so involved with the
storytelling aspects and that's what we
were trying to do with some of the stuff
we're doing like the expressions packs
we have we had a packs on I think's on
the back one of those sheets there's
actually a Batman Joker
yeah the holy I was in the I saw the
drawing at the bottom he was on this
what does that mean exactly this batty
says oh we were gonna be cute and make
Batman have all the same expressions but
gonna buy that that's fun but Joker and
Harley and Batman all these head you can
pop on and often there's other things
they come with the Batman so it comes
with different couple different capes it
comes with like a super angry Batman it
comes with the surprise Batman with the
wide white eyes and stuff and it comes
with a Bruce Wayne head and the Joker
one has his expressions are so great no
and what's fun about this besides
customizing them to your very every mood
that day you can actually really start
interacting more with the figures that's
just one way we're trying to get back
into some of the we creating the scenes
or the storytelling from the actual
actual show ace the bat-hound man that's
a figure worth having right there never
thought you'd see one of those yeah or
you've been doing Batman Beyond again
not show it that's also great and you
can go down the well there's like
characters that appeared on that show
that didn't appear yeah a lot of cool
what is it like to work at a Dream
Factory like this where like do you get
to walk in any day and go like oh I got
an idea or does somebody go here are the
ideas you execute no it's literally with
the design team and even not if you're
on the design team we have you have a
production team and a business team and
ideas can come from anywhere hmm
so we usually try to plan out you know
we plan out the whole year pretty far in
advance as it takes a while to make the
stuff but if someone's got a good idea
I'm willing to listen to whoever it is
as long as it's something that makes
sense so it's a pretty free form for
that and it's actually amazing to work
at a place where this is your job right
I mean I'd even though this when I was a
kid I know this was a job you know stuff
just showed up in a toy store you know
toys are here yeah but I go by them Anna
must have brought them you grew up to be
Santa awesome you know you beat the
system yeah I got called Santa once
again of jury duty but that's a story
for another day
but yeah it's great cuz you're having a
job you can really walk in and just give
that much to the products we're making I
mean these you know sitting on even
watching the episodes and figure out
what accessories should come with it he
like that's when you get stuff like
Bane's barbell showing up and you know
they think you could put so much stuff
with these but which ones do you pick
now all right so you take suggestions in
terms of DC merchandise what mark
barnard and would you suggest what do
you think is missing and it could be not
for this line just a DC in general like
I will say that there should be like a
play-doh DC team-up 4 feet of clay funny
you brought up that clay face thing cuz
when we made that claiming that also a
giant clay face toys in a box like might
this be we had a lot of conversations
and somebody actually said that yeah but
we were trying to figure out what do you
do with this clay face because he's very
plot obviously very pliable one of the
things I wanted to do originally you
know where Batman's head get stuck I
come halfway out I want to actually add
that oh that's cool we couldn't really
figure out how to do it at the time but
yeah that I got thrown in there so I
figure has a box it's like it's pretty
good most of the figures it's bigger
it's like maybe half the size of this
box it's pretty big buddy huh yes he has
a ball and chain hand and all those
other hands in a couple of in a yelling
head and a regular head it was a really
cool piece but stuff like that
it's really cool to figure out how do
you make them so it resonates with the
show and you can play with it more but
that's pretty funny I'm just gonna say
are you allowed to have a favorite
episode yeah what is it I'm going wait
I'm going DC merge sort of destiny spear
of destiny
oh yeah other stuff you want me mate I'm
not saying you have to but you could
definitely make a spear bath place your
orders for thing you want to list okay
go ahead these might be new ones we're
trying to think I mean you guys have
done the lantern in the green land yeah
well buncha different colors and we know
that there's a dr. fade helmet so maybe
one day Sandman helmet which we didn't
even know that could be so maybe that
way that was pretty great in the DC you
know I mean really you guys have done so
much the only thing left is to start
selling like living pets like Quinto
well we did make must ones that's true
we guys
well even the Joker fish yeah which was
so did I love that joke can you think of
anything in the DC Universe that needs
to be physically manifested ooh from the
show even I mean I don't know if you
could pull it off but but dr.
Manhattan's Crystal Palace on Mars full
size I mean yeah what the moon in the
toys really man but that's cool I'll put
that on there my back pocket just I'm
sorry who from the Batman animated
series line do our losing hasn't been
done you you guys have done scarecrow
yeah both oh no we've only done one
scarecrow which one first we did no we
did the second one do we need a new
Batman adventures
yeah they're really creepy one we had
never did the first one so there you go
that's a good one gentleman ghost nope
nothing good one who did Adam West play
Gray Ghost you've done there has been a
great ghost figure not from us but yes
that's already been produced once yet so
then now there's there's we kind of feel
like me to get on now and that's pretty
cool you know what I'm saying especially
right now I mean there's so many great
other people just hey you know which
ones to pick I mean even coming the way
we come up with them we try to figure
out we have a giant whiteboard that we
can write all this stuff on it sometimes
it just comes down to an arm-wrestling
contest of what's gonna who's gonna win
you know matter of choice yeah all right
so good is there an aura freeze now
that's good no no in the tank I'm like
the revolt we actually did it snow globe
for the Arkham Asylum game we did we did
a big giant mr. freeze figure and by the
nor he's holding her and she's like this
big but that's deep cuts if they look
mom can I get the nor freeze in the
froze tank please in the crime what do
you what a dead girl is a toy because
that's what they did on the show that
dead yet yeah he's trying to save her ma
you're not romantic and you think you
say we make an adult toys earlier I
believe I'd say you introduced it so you
know these are grown-up toys but kids
can play with this stuff yeah but I had
a kid and they took this out of the
package I boot you're not my kid anymore
that's awful expensive I'm gonna get you
a low price you gotta give her a name
change and everything this and all the
merchandise you guys are making Harley
Quinn of course it's her birthday as
well or anniversary of her creation
Harley Quinn merchandise still flying
office oh yeah I mean sometimes Harley
is the best selling thing depending on
what the line is I mean we we have a
whole heart we have a whole line of
Harley red white and black statues I
mean I know you're very familiar with
our Batman black and white statue has
been going to our longest running line
the Harley line in some cases is
starting to outperform even Batman which
is just crazy oh my lord when the
villains beat the heroes I mean that so
you're saying it like women are buying
toys based on comic books yeah I believe
that Jim that feels like [ __ ] to me
well okay go into copper conventions
when you were younger which I'm sure all
of us did yeah you didn't see a whole
lot of women at all it was a bunch of
old dudes selling complex out of boxes
we have the some of the lines we've done
now have really resonated with women we
have the bombshells line we do which we
have a lot of cosplayers showing up and
in those costumes and we got a lot of
responses from women on this you know
even this this line the show is
resonating so heavily I wouldn't be too
surprised if a lot of know the purchases
for this one hour even some of you have
women and have grown up on the show when
they were girls so it's that whole
dynamics changed completely
I think and we definitely yeah and you
guys have done like you did well of
course you did back row they've done
Roxy rocket you've done Catwoman that
was one that we only did that nobody
else had done and the rock Paul Dini was
super jazzed about that he came in we
were sculpting it we showed him when it
was finished and he was like finally
this week yummy so he was really happy
he's been great to work right that
Paul's been he's seen a lot of stuff
that we've done you know we've talked to
Bruce as well a lot a couple of things
and showed him what we're doing and he's
been you know there's a lot of people
have been really helping us out with
some of the reference and you know just
going through the stuff I it's
everyone's so happy to see you come out
here's my my American more-more-more
here's my request so you know how own it
I'm like I want more yeah you know how
they take those Star Wars figures and
they make him does a blends yet you got
to do that with these I know we're
talking with just like Batman and
these like because there are points of
articulation doesn't seem like these are
pretty straightforward I mean they're
not the crazy search imagine I don't
like well I always imagined evidence
never comes true but could you imagine
having like a four foot something like
that three foot version well you don't
have to imagine the one-to-one Harley we
made at Comic Cons do you guys digital
we made it we made a six-foot Harley
statue at which Harley I have the brute
this one from the the Paul Dini Bruce
Timm Batman animated series Harley it's
for sale well we're working on it we
made a real one it's it's like huge it
was on a big base so if one was gonna
eventually make those for mass
production you wouldn't mass but like if
you made something like that probably
how much would something like that cost
because I must start saving now well
we're trying to figure it out it's got
to be in the thousands somewhere I mean
if we can get it down around 5 grand
that'd be great that's how much that
statue is but we're working we're
working diligently on that dude I know
there's some people out there going
you're crazy that'd be worth it it looks
it looks amaze me a lot of people take
pictures of that I mean the kid after
that Karen I know you'd have to forgive
me but I want that large statute well we
could always cut the head off and sculpt
your daughter's head on and put that on
them I mean a stove oven not her real
hair very true yes okay mom we clear
that up a little bit tall as the move
man I think that's that's what other
people like Oh take it they move a bunch
of like life-size frozen Han Solo's like
yeah yes why wouldn't you be able to
move this stuff especially to be able to
yet nevermind bitching about what you
didn't bring what you brought it's
fantastic this is for not complaining
about what I am brave Airy very trying
to believe it and bring it all you are
doing the Lord's work Jim you continue
to do well thanks for being an
evangelist my stuff you got love to I
love to preach I love to tell people
about the good news when you find
something good you want to tell other
people about it this is a whole good
every we've really tried to bring it to
a new level of detail and everything on
these toys we've been super proud of
this line for a long time you are
honoring the bat on the 25th anniversary
of one of his finest
incarnation yeah right we salute you sir
there it is folks save your pennies go
out and get one of these build the line
if you're building the line already you
got a bunch all right keep going
together get go this isn't far yeah
that's right and also you know what I
know some people said they're gone
if only how hard do you work how hard
you work for other people aren't you
always doing [ __ ] for give me single
that mine take it which I'm gonna take
this that's what you always doing [ __ ]
for other people aren't you always
looking out for others is one moment
your life we get to look out for
yourself go buy this this is your treat
and if you've got like a wife or a
husband that's just like don't spend
money on that this is yours man this is
your time give up a couple other things
because this is totally worth having
there I've said my piece by les
Starbucks a week
oh nice savings plan you know they say I
had no plan whatsoever I was like the
president we're gonna cut taxes and
change things I had no plan you know one
less Starbucks a week I mean it's pretty
strong too so you could probably save
one putting the microwave yeah one less
coffee and this is yours Wow how many
weeks with that 20 that's not terrible
and so performance right before
Christmas yeah we got time there there's
your plan we didn't work there it is
folks for fat man on Batman I've been
Kevin Smith I've been mark the Norden
who you and I've been Jim Fletcher and
we're out and get this go out and
support DC collectibles because they're
making the stuff we always dreamed they
would make that's why I buy this stuff
sometimes I see stuff where I'm like
look but my wife goes do you really need
that my wife says like won't they give
that to for free
and I said that's not the point that
this exists needs to be supportive
because nobody buys it it goes away and
the fact that it's here makes my heart
soar so I like to I like to spend money
on this stuff this was nice they bring
the cash for this today not stupid
nobody thanks guys tune in next episode
same fad time same fat channel SModcast
calm or you dude Kevin Smith the best
Killer Croc
Unicom / Kevin Smith nor this was better
than the one that they gave me
[Music]
you